hailer 5 is out tomorrow which means a
bunch of you guys are gearing up to jump
back into one of the biggest franchises
in all of gaming in light of that here's
four of the ways that halo changed the
cause of console FPS games
anybody who's ever played an action or
shooter game on the Nintendo 64 can
probably tell you the horrors of camera
angles that never let you precisely
target what you want the same issue
which made Zed targeting your best
friend in Zelda games was well and truly
solved by halos new control scheme I'm a
big fan of the n64 but I think we can
all now agree that two sticks are better
than one hailer was the first major FPS
game to use and popularize the twin
stick control scheme from movement all
of a sudden you could navigate through
the world with the left stick while
using the right to adjust your crosshair
and viewpoint at the same time that
control system is still in use to this
day of many years later for a very good
reason
and as a result of precision shooting
and movement is far easier to execute on
consoles depleting health and health
pack pickups can be a tricky thing to
balance in games but Taylor left that
quandary behind by introducing
regenerating shields whether hailer was
the absolute first FPS to feature
regenerating health is hard to say but
it certainly popularized the feature
Master Chief is equipped with super
handy future tech armor complete with a
regenerating shield to protect his
twitchy self after being dealt a
particularly nasty beating Master Chief
can pop behind a chest high wall for a
few seconds take a breather and wait for
those shields to get back up before
diving back into battle now needs a nod
for vitality booths during battle like
you would in Return to Castle
Wolfenstein or Red Faction simply pace
yourself and then pick up a health pack
or two later once everybody else is out
cold
you can thank hailer for all those
shootouts you've narrowly won in other
FPS games thanks to a cleverly timed
shield regen on top of that halo also
limited you to two weapons all thing you
to get clever about the best ways to
take out your opponent and consider the
most effective strategies with what you
had long firefights usually meant you
ran out of ammo had to pick up an enemy
weapon and learn how to use that in a
pinch hello also individually mapped
Malia tacks and grenades to their own
dead
two buttons on the controller which made
it much easier to knock out a foe or
blow them to smithereens at a moment's
notice
speeding up their destruction or as the
case may be your own as it turns out all
those improved combat features and
smoother movement systems would be
necessary as halo introduced enemies
that were actually smart enemies
equipped with brains as well as brawn
meant that you needed to become a better
combatant to yourself to win out
unlike the predictable enemy behavior in
shooters of days gone by bows in Halo
would respond differently depending on a
number of combat variables enemies would
flank you jump out of the way of
speeding vehicles elites would charge
mercilessly if they had the upper hand
and grunts could be expected to panic
inflate their patrol either be defeated
the improved AI also greatly affected
enemy behavior depending on the
difficulty level you opted for that
ranged from soft-hearted weaklings on
the easiest settings to 3s and
unreasonably clever and ruthless
opponents in halos legendary difficulty
mode and finally while Halo 5 has
dropped split-screen we'd be remiss not
to mention that innovation as well as
the integration of multiplayer that was
both smooth and efficient while halo
invented neither multiplayer or
split-screen it did make them both work
really well and in cooperation with your
local network halo was the game you
threw LAN parties for it's the games
that encourage you to get your friends
over and spend all night completing the
campaign or juking it out in Slayer
matches even after perfectly solid Xbox
Live connections were established to let
you play co-op remotely if online was or
is your gem you have halo to thank the
sky rocketing xbox live in two
significant and delivering online
matchmaking the worked surprisingly well
with little to no connectivity issues
let me know down in that comment section
what halo feature is your favorite and I
will see you next time